[Music]
I'm sitting here with my friend comedian
Byron bers great set man thank you thank
you yeah real
nice those are some those are some cool
ass pants too oh thank you brother I
appreciate it man you in the fashion
well they got they got people that give
me this jacket okay we have a tin girl
someone just from the drawers oh I need
that's I need the drawer person drawer
girls yeah I need two of them you know
what I mean one for each leg and then
maybe somebody in the middle to get the
middle just a taint person yeah just
that taint here's why I bring it up
every time I see you you are dressed
really well and we always like to play a
game uh with the comics called either or
would you play fashion either or with me
okay go it's like a speed round okay
jeans or slacks jeans jeans all
day plad or flannel or both uh let's do
both good choice let's mix it up a
little bit huh
it's like wine and
whiskey that's
disgusting but you living That's What I
Call living right there true enough
sweatpants or parachute pants Oh depends
on the function I'm going to go with
sweatpants me too I like that sweatpants
don't act like they're trying to hide
your boner that's true that's true you
ever had a boner in parachute pants
before I call that pulling the rip cord
Byron b everybody one more
timeon that is our
[Music]
show